Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast für Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten,
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja hier ist äh sie schon die Ausgabe Nummer zweiundneunzig von Raumzeit und heute ist es mal wieder Zeit ähm,
zurückzublicken, denn,
Hauptsache gibt's jetzt schon so lange, ähm dass es äh langsam ganz angemessen ist, alte Themen mal wieder aufzugreifen, weil wie es ja so ist, die Dinge schreiten voran und äh so in zehn Jahren kann sich dann doch schon so einiges,
ändern. Also dachte ich mir, müsste man auch die Entwicklung im Bereich von,
Weltraum, Schrott und äh generell der Verkehrsproblematik im Orbit nochmal neu äh aufgreifen,
dazu greife ich einfach auf meinen Gesprächspartner von der siebten Raumzeitfolge von ja wie gesagt fast zehn Jahren äh zurück, nämlich den Holger, Holger Krack, hallo Holger.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, ist schon äh eine Weile her, dass wir gesprochen haben, du bist aber immer noch im selben Business und äh an derselben Position, die sich vielleicht ein bisschen äh verändert haben durfte, aber für bist immer noch bei der,
Bei der E-Sorg bei der Raumfahrt, äh beim Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum in Darmstadt. Und ähm ja, ist dann Thema treu geblieben.
Ja, das Thema spannend und das beschäftigt uns jetzt mehr und mehr in der Raumfahrtagentur Esa. Und ähm ich kann auch gleich vorab schicken. Es wird immer anstrengender und immer stressiger, denn es ist immer mehr los.
Ja, ist immer mehr los. Ja, vielleicht mal so einen kleinen äh Rückblick. Ich habe auch selber nochmal in die Sendung äh reingehört, die wir äh da eben vor zehn Jahren gemacht haben. Und das war so ein bisschen mehr so eine Situationsbeschreibung.
Dir eigentlich äh vor allem ja Aktionen eingefordert hat. Äh sechzehntausend Objekte wurden damals gezählt, also das sind halt Satelliten und solche, die vielleicht äh irgendwann mal in viele Teile zerspringt wurden,
ähm Satelliten haben sich äh entweder durch Kollisionen oder eben auch durch Selbstentzündung und Explosion äh zerlegt,
es gab einige Vorfälle wo auch absichtlich Kollisionen herbeigeführt wurden und ja ihr habt im Prinzip damals so,
Position gehabt, na ja, also wenn sich da nicht bald was ändert, dann äh wird's anstrengend, wie der jetzt schon vorweggenommen hat, so kam es dann auch, denn,
Ja, der Verkehr nimmt zu. Und ähm.
Was auch ganz interessant war ist ähm vor allem richtete sich der Blick ja damals auf die ganzen Raumfahrtagenturen. Nun haben wir ja in den letzten zehn Jahren,
interessanten Wandel erlebte, private Sektor ist wirklich sehr viel stärker geworden äh vor allem aber nicht nur Space X, zahlreiche Lounges äh,
sehr viele Objekte, die halt dazu gekommen sind und vor allem einen immer noch nicht wirklich derzeit angepasstes Weltraumrecht.
Insgesamt macht auch gerade die Erde nicht gerade so den Eindruck, als ob sie viel Lust hat, sich international groß zu einigen, was äh solche Weltraumressourcen betrifft.
Ähm.
Ja, wir haben so ein paar Ideen damals debattiert und jetzt würde ich halt ganz gerne mal daran anknüpfen und mal äh schauen, was denn dabei eigentlich herausgekommen ist. Denn ähm ja, also damals war schon klar,
Die Agenturen haben sich verpflichtet, künftige Missionen so auszustatten, dass sie zumindest theoretisch äh wieder alles zurückführen können, dass man äh entweder, wenn man ganz weit draußen ist, äh noch etwas weiter rausschreitet, um die geostationieren,
Obit Platz frei zu machen oder eben entsprechend, wenn man in niedrigen Orbits unterwegs ist, dass man dann äh entsprechend dafür sorgen kann,
dass so ein Gerät innerhalb von fünfundzwanzig Jahren spätestens abstürzt und verglüht und damit auch keine weiteren Probleme mehr macht.
Wie sieht's denn so aus?
Ja
Haben sich denn irgendwelche Wünsche erfüllt.
Ja, lass mich, lass mich vielleicht mal mit den Zahlen anfangen. Ähm sechzehntausend, äh, das war die Zahl, die du gerade genannt hast vor zehn Jahren.
Du hast die genannt vor zehn Jahren.
Du hast äh du hast die genannt, dass ich die genannt habe,
Ähm und das ist, das ist richtig, das ist damit meinen wir die Objekte, die vom Boden aus verfolgt werden können und die, die wir mit Namen kennen, äh die wir mit Positionen kennen und bei denen wir auch vorher sagen können, wo die sein werden, was ganz wichtig ist.
Diese Zahl hat sich vergrößert auf dreiundzwanzigtausend, das ist ein großer Sprung. Ähm das sind Objekte mit so.
Mindestgröße von zehn Zentimeter, also schon ganz ordentlich, ähm um das mal klar zu machen bei einer Kollision eines Satelliten mit einem von den Objekten.
Haben wir es mit einem Totalschaden zu tun. Das heißt, es äh der Satellit geht nicht nur kaputt, sondern und funktioniert nicht mehr, sondern er zerlegt sich auch noch in zusätzliche Trümmer,
mit den entsprechenden Folgen, die diese Trümmer dann nach sich ziehen, wenn sie im All bleiben. Und davon gibt es jetzt dreiundzwanzigtausend. Ähm das ist ein Schritt in die falsche Richtung, ganz klar.
Und wir beobachten, dass Explosionen, du hast es genannt, ähm,
die lassen sich anscheinend nicht so ohne Weiteres abstellen. Ähm dass Objekte im All sich nach einer Zeit von selber zerlegen, weil restliche Treibstoffe an Bord sind, Batterien aufgeladen sind,
und die eben Sachen machen im All, nachdem sie außer Kontrolle geraten sind, ähm
in diesem sehr sehr aggressiven Wirement, ähm wenn diese Sonne auf die falsche Seite scheint, das reicht alleine schon über und die Zeit tut den Rest nach Jahren oder Jahrzehnten im All ermüdet das Material und sie brechen auf
Warum passiert das auch heute noch? Äh acht Mal pro Jahr, obwohl wir doch schon längst äh wie du gesagt.
Mal pro Jahr explodiert ein Satellit.
Richtig, nicht immer der gleiche, also achte acht acht Satelliten im pro Jahr oder auch Raketenstufen, die ziehen wir damit rein.
Das ist die gleiche Durchschnittszahl die wir in der Vergangenheit auch haben. Was was verdammt nochmal,
hindert diese Effekte daran ähm nach wie vor sowieso stark aufzutreten. Warum gibt es die noch? Äh wir haben doch bereits,
sehr oft Vermeidungsmaßnahmen implementiert, wo der restliche Treibstoff abgelassen wird, wo Batterien entladen werden, das ist auch schon alles,
ein alter Hut und wird überall gefordert und sogar gemacht. Und trotzdem passiert es und ähm wenn man dann genauer hinschaut, merkt man, das sind dann oft doch noch sehr alte Objekte, mit denen das passiert. Ähm.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, selbst wenn man heute was beschließt die Raumfahrt dauert, da dauern die Prozesse extrem lange. Ein Beschluss heute,
wird in einen Satelliten eingebaut, der,
in fünf Jahren startet, denn so lange dauert die Entwicklungsphase und so eine neue, eine neue Anforderung an den Satelliten,
die muss natürlich erst, kann natürlich erst am Anfang der Entwicklungsphase aufgestellt werden,
dann fliegt der fünf Jahre, aber es gibt auch Satelliten, die alte Dinosaurier sind und die fliegen dann mal fünfzehn Jahre. Mhm. Und dann äh merkt man erst zwanzig Jahre später. Ähm ob das nun geklappt hat äh mit dem Ablassen vom Treibstoff oder nicht.
Und wir haben also noch sehr viele Altlasten, das ist ein Teil der Erklärung, aber ein weiterer Teil glaube ich ist wir haben es mit mangelnder Technologie zu tun, denn.
Oft passiert es, dass ein Satellit schon direkt nach dem Start,
von vornherein gar nicht funktioniert. Das ist eben komplexe Technologie. Ähm setzt man einen Satelliten im All einmal aus, ähm ist man darauf angewiesen, dass er auf Funksignale antwortet,
dass man ihm kommandieren kann, was er zu machen hat, bricht aus irgendeinem Grund, aus irgendeinem technischen Fehler, der Kontakt zusammen.
Hat man keine Chance mehr auf den Satelliten einzuwirken. Ähm.
Es sei denn so ein Schutzprogramm wird äh dann aktiv.
Oder? Oder, dass es schwebt uns vor? Ähm,
wenn man, wenn der Satellit also direkt nach dem Start verloren gegangen ist, voll mit Treibstoff, mit vollgeladenen Batterien, dann gibt es, kann es nur mitunter eine Katastrophe geben. Äh man kann ihn nur nicht mal befehlen, äh entlaste den Treibstoff, weil man einfach keinen Kontakt mehr hat. Hätte man aber,
von Anfang an ein zusätzliches Gerät eingebaut, was ähm separat auf Funksignale reagiert,
Unabhängig von dem Satelliten. Und was äh zum Beispiel eine Entsorgung durchführt oder oder die sind das Ablassen des Treibstoffs durch externe Mittel.
Das würde, das wäre sozusagen eine zusätzliche Rendanz bedeuten und das könnte das Problem beheben. Und deswegen glauben wir, dass ähm ich bin überzeugt, dass wir Technologien brauchen, die in diese Richtung gehen.
Also wäre das sozusagen so ein separater äh Controller, der,
wie so eine Todbandschaltung funktioniert, also solange die Rakete sagt so, nee, alles super, ich habe alles unter Kontrolle, passt schon, du äh musst hier nicht aktiv werden, soweit äh bleibt das Ding sozusagen ruhig, aber,
kaum, dass die Rakete sich nicht mehr meldet und sagt, ja, weiß auch nicht, dass sie dann halt sagt, ja okay, mein, wenn du nichts dazu zu sagen hast, dann äh entlasse ich jetzt hier mal alle.
Äh treibt.
Ja, genau, so ist es. Also, es ist wie so, wenn da der Strom fällt aus und dann läuft eine Uhr. Man hat noch drei Tage Zeit zu reagieren, um ihn nochmal irgendwie retten kann, wenn nicht, wird automatisch eingeleitet, Treibstoff ablassen,
und das das aus dem Orbit manövrieren, das wird dann einfach automatisch durchgeführt. Wenn ich das so sage, macht das vielleicht viele nervös, denn wenn der Satellit mehrere Millionen kostet, dann hätte man gern noch mehr als drei Tage, um um um das Leben des Satelliten zu kämpfen
Aber ich glaube, es hilft nichts. Ähm bei den bei den Zahlen von Objekten, die wir starten wollen, brauchen wir sowas.
Und sehe, dass auch andere Leute so.
Es sehen auch andere Leute so, ich glaube, dass sich die die Erkenntnis durchsetzt, dass man,
nicht ausreicht, nur auf dem Papier darauf zu achten, dass ähm ein Objekt in der Lage ist, diese ganzen Maßnahmen durchzuführen. Man muss auch.
Ähnlich wie beim beim Auto macht man das ja auch, ne? Es reicht ja nicht, wenn einer einen Führerschein hat und das Auto in Ordnung ist, wenn es aus der Batterie kommt, sondern man muss noch alle zwei Jahre zu TÜV,
und das Auto vorstellen und dann guckt einer unten drunter und äh der bescheinigt einen dann okay, du kannst nochmal zwei Jahre fahren. Das machen wir in der Raumfahrt noch nicht
da wird ähm da wird vor dem Start mal geguckt, aber äh wenn dann zwei Jahre später,
wichtige Komponenten ausgefallen sind und der Satellit wird noch weiter betrieben und man gefährdet damit die Durchführung der Maßnahmen am Ende dann wird dann noch nicht so unbedingt drauf geguckt und ähm wenn man sich davon sozusagen,
durch ein schönes Stück Technologie davon freikaufen kann und man hat das von Anfang an an Bord. Das denke ich, äh das denke ich wäre attraktiv. Es darf natürlich nicht teuer sein,
das wäre ja mal eine schöne Aufgabe für der Raumfahrtagentur dafür zu sorgen, dass sowas für einen günstigen Preis zu haben ist.
Katastrophal sind denn diese Selbstexplosionen? Also ich hab ja eigentlich gelernt, der Explodieren tut ja immer alles nur bei Star Wars. Weil ohne Sauerstoff kann ja dann nicht jetzt so viel passieren, aber,
andererseits das natürlich Raketentriebwerke, die brennen ja schon ein bisschen. Was, was findet da konkret statt und wie, wie desaströs sind solche Explosionen.
Ja, also da macht man sich keinen Begriff von, die sind äh die sind eine Katastrophe für die Raumfahrt. Ähm Treibstoff, Treibstoff ist oft der Sauerstoffträger selbst mit enthalten. Ähm.
Bereit erreicht äh als Auslöser zum Beispiel einen Einschlag eines Mikropartikels oder einfach ein Aufwärmen des Tanks. Dann gibt's eine exoterne Reaktion und ähm es gibt einen Druckbärsten Distanz,
und es gibt auch Treibstoffe, die die reagieren miteinander explosiv und,
Das bedeutet, dass äh die Trümmer, die dabei entstehen, die bleiben nicht irgendwie begrenzt auf auf einen kleinen Raum, um den Ort der Explosion, sondern ähm die werden weggeschleudert.
Teilweise mit ähm bis zu hundert Meter pro Sekunde äh und damit ändern die nicht nur ihre Position, sondern die ändern quasi ihre Bahn, die verschmutzen.
Über ein Jahr gesehen.
Die gesamte Höhenschale, die findet man überall. Äh und zwar plus minus hundert Kilometer um den äh Explosionsort herum. Über den ganzen Globus verteilt, hat jeder was davon,
und ich weiß wovon ich rede, weil äh in der in der europäischen Raumfahrtagentur betreiben wir auch eine Satellitenflotte mit mit sehr teuren Umwelt und äh Erdbeobachtungsatelien, zwanzig Stück zur Zeit.
Und jedes Mal, wenn sowas passiert, ähm bekommen wir Kollisionswarnungen, auch wenn wir zum Beispiel hundert Kilometer da drunter fliegen.
Oder an einem ganz anderen Ort sind. Das ist heute das der Alltag, ähm dass wir dass man nichts bleibt im im All isoliert. Äh die Raumfahrt,
teilt sich im Prinzip die Ressource all. Ähm wird sich gemeinsam, wird gemeinsam genutzt. Jeder, der sie verschmutzt,
zieht alle anderen in Mitleidenschaft und das ist das merken wir jeden Tag.
Meine so ein Teil, wenn so eine Explosion stattfindet, dann wird ja natürlich auch einiges mehr oder weniger auch direkt in der Atmosphäre gejagt. So, also,
nur nur ein Teil davon verbleibt ja jetzt wirklich auch in dieser selben Obitalen äh Bewegung, aber es ist immer noch genug, um eine Menge Ärger einzustellen.
Immer noch genug. Leider verschwinden die wenigsten. Äh in die in die Atmosphäre. Das würden wir uns wünschen. Ähm,
Es gibt ja auch immer noch Anti-Satellitentests, damit damit meinen wir, dass das Satelliten,
Vom Boden aus zum Beispiel mit einer Misseil abgeschossen werden zu Demonstrationszwecken, dass man in der Lage ist, militärisch auch im Weltraum eingreifen zu können, meiner Meinung nach komplett überflüssig das zu zeigen, aber es hat sich,
offensichtlich eingebürgert, dass jede Großmacht im Alter, dass mindestens einmal zeigen muss. Ähm, ich, wir hoffen sehr, sehr stark, dass das nachlässt. Ähm,
denn nicht alle führen diese Tests so durch, dass diese Fragmente, die dabei entstehen, ähm,
muss sich das so vorstellen, das ist ein das ist dazu ist noch nicht mal eine exklusive Ladung erforderlich, sondern da wird einfach zwei Objekte miteinander zur Kollision gebracht, nämlich der Kopf von der Nissa und der Satellit, der dagegen fliegt.
Und allein,
Der Aufschlag mechanisch reicht aus, um die Objekte zu zerlegen und passiert das in Höhen von äh oberhalb sechshundert Kilometer bleiben die Fragmente über zwanzig oder mehr Jahre im All,
passiert das in achthundert Kilometer bleiben die mitunter bis zu hundert Jahre im All.
Und passiert das in tausend Kilometer bleiben sie für immer im All, das liegt an der abnehmenden Dichte der Atmosphäre nach außen hin, die eben weniger bremsend wirkt, je dünner sie ist,
Und ähm dazu führt, dass die Objekte dann länger im Ball bleiben.
Das hatten wir ja vor zehn Jahren schon. Da äh hatte China äh das mal gemacht. Jetzt gab's aber wohl im März zwanzig neunzehn nochmal so eine Aktion diesmal von äh den Innern.
Was also ich meine haben die.
Haben die diesen Podcast noch nicht gehört oder was ist das Problem? Also das ist doch sozusagen jetzt nicht neu, dass das eine schlechte Idee ist.
Sie haben vielleicht gehört und haben gemerkt, dass es eine schlechte Idee und man kann's ein bisschen besser machen, wenn man einen Zielsatelliten aussucht, der tiefer fliegt.
Du kannst dir vorstellen, dass das immer noch keine Begeisterungsstürme ausgelöst in der Welt. Ähm der Satellit war in dreihundert knapp dreihundert Kilometer Höhe.
Das bedeutet immer noch, dass die Objekte Wochen beziehungsweise Monate im All bleiben nicht schön, denn auch da unten,
findet Raumfahrt statt. Zum Beispiel die internationale Raumstation, die ist nicht weit weg davon. Ähm warum das sein muss, ähm das können die nur selber beantworten. Ähm aber sagen wir mal so.
Der Schritt ging in die richtige Richtung, man hat zumindest ein Ziel ausgewählt, was ähm was dazu führt, dass die Fragmente nicht so allzu lange im Ball bleiben.
Was hat er das jetzt für konkrete Auswirkungen? Also äh beim ESOR, beim Raubfahrtkontrollzentrum seid ihr im Prinzip die ganze Zeit dabei, alle möglichen Missionen zu führen und ich weiß nicht
irgendwann habe ich glaube ich immer gefragt, wie viel Mission es derzeit denn eigentlich so gleichzeitig sind, haut das so hin, fünfundzwanzig Missionen, so in der Größenordnung, die so ungefähr äh gerade gelingt werden.
Ähm das ja schon eine ganze Menge. Was, was sieht man denn dann davon von dem Ganzen,
Schrott und überhaupt von dem Verkehrswesen, was da jetzt sozusagen entstanden ist.
Ich muss da schmunzeln, denn leider sehen wir gar nichts. Äh da um was zu sehen, müsst muss man ziemlichen Aufwand betreiben, denn die Objekte melden sich ja nicht von selber. Sie sind tot in der Regel,
sind äh nicht aktiv, senden kein Signal.
Man muss sie aktiv aufspüren. Teleskop, Rader, gewaltigen Aufwand muss man am Boden betreiben, um das durchführen zu können. Das machen zu heute zur Zeit nur immer noch nach wie vor, wie vor zehn Jahren.
Hauptsächlich die Amerikaner. Ähm wir kommen in Europa jetzt so langsam hinterher. Ähm wir,
Wir sind dankbar, dass diese Daten aus Amerika äh mit uns geteilt werden, zeitnah, umfangreich, es ist sehr, sehr gut, was ist unglaublich, was die können, ohne dass wir völlig undenkbar die Raumfahrt so zu betreiben, wie wir das tun. Wir brauchen diese Daten.
Nicht wegzudenken und in Europa wollen wir dazu beisteuern. Wir wir können komplementär dazu,
mit eigenen Sensoren mithelfen. Mehr Sensoren machen die Daten genauer. Mehr Sensoren sehen mehr Objekte, ja? Das hilft der Raumfahrtsicherheit.
Aber wir sind noch nicht so weit, dass wir dass wir wirklich ein ebenbürtiges Gegengesicht gegen das liefern können, was wir aus den USA bekommen. Also wir sind, man muss es sagen, immer noch eigentlich blind gegenüber der Situation.
Dazu ist ja eigentlich ein Projekt gestartet worden, die Space Situational Wellness ähm hatte ich auch mit Detlef äh Koschni schon mal drüber gesprochen, ist allerdings auch schon äh gut acht Jahre her. Ähm mehr als acht Jahre sogar sehe ich gerade,
Da war das Ganze noch in der frühen Planung, da geht's ja noch ein bisschen mehr als nur um um Weltraumschrotter, das Wetter noch mit drin, äh, diverse andere Konstellationen
wie hat sich das denn entwickelt? Du bist ja jetzt auch aktiv mit dabei, oder?
Ja, genau, das Programm hat sich deutlich weiterentwickelt, das heißt jetzt ähm Raumfahrtsicherheitsprogramm, Spacety.
Und das Programm hat auch erweiterten Horizont, also wir schauen uns jetzt nicht nur die Techniken an, die man braucht, um die Objekte zu entdecken.
Sondern wir schauen uns auch die Technologie an, die man braucht, um die Objekte loszuwerden. Und das ist der nächste Schritt und wir sind äh mit der Technik weitergekommen. Äh man es gibt heute in Europa,
zwei Großradeanlagen, die nicht zuletzt sind nationale Entwicklungen, aber die basieren auf ursprünglichen,
Technologien, die wir aus dem ESA-Programm entwickelt haben. Eins steht in Spanien und eins steht in Deutschland, in Koblenz und die werden innerhalb weniger Wochen oder Monate werden die operationell sein und die werden dann zum ersten Mal,
Und da sind wir, sind wir glücklich darüber, dass wir aus Europa auch eigenständig Daten mit Radar bekommen? Ansonsten haben wir es geschafft.
Ein Netzwerk von optischen Teleskopen, verschiedener Betreiber in Europa,
aufzustellen, die die Objekte beobachten, die ein bisschen weiter draußen sind, ja. Fünfunddreißigtausend Kilometer von der Sonne beschienen werden,
Und das reflektierte Sonnenlicht ähm einfangen und damit kann man auch die Position ermitteln. Das funktioniert,
und darauf sind wir auch sehr stolz. Leser ist was Fantastisches. Leser ist ist quasi ein Radar im optischen Bereich. Man kann damit hochgenau,
Entfernung bestimmen.
Der Durchbruch der letzten Jahre ist, dass man normalerweise bekommt man Laserstrahl, Echo von dem Satelliten zurückgeworfen, wenn da einen kleinen Spiegel an Bord hat,
sogenannter Retoreflektor. Das haben natürlich die Schrottobjekte nicht, aber mit dem bei einem Leser in mit der richtigen Pulsfrequenz und auch der richtigen Leistung,
schaffen wir es heute auch einzelne Photonen ähm von äh von Weltraumschrott zurückgeworfen, aufzuzeichnen unten am Teleskop und damit die Entfernung zu bemessen und ähm seit ein paar Wochen sogar am Tag.
Normalerweise funktioniert es nur in der Nacht. Und ich, das ist ein interessanter Weg, ähm denn,
Damit könnten wir in Europa einen Beitrag leisten, der nicht das dupliziert, was in Amerika sowieso schon gemacht wird, nämlich einfach mal breitbandig, denn das ganze All äh zu beobachten.
Also visuell zu beobachten vor allem.
Visuell und vor allen Dingen festzustellen, was was neu ist und ähm und uns neue Sachen aufzunehmen mit in die in die Umfassung, sondern wir können schon vorhandene Sachen viel, viel genauer bearbeiten und das.
Das wäre ein sehr sehr toller Beitrag aus Europa, wo denn Genauigkeit der Daten das ganz wichtig. Ich weiß das, weil in dem in dem Betrieb von Satelliten.
Haben wir es mit sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr vielen Kollisionswarnungen zu tun, mehrere hundert pro Tag,
das ist äh noch mehr als damals vor zehn Jahren. Und fast also eigentlich alle davon sind Fehlahme. Fehlernarme. Ähm wir können sie nur nicht von den richtigen Alarm unterscheiden, weil die Genauigkeit der Daten nicht ausreicht.
Oft manövrieren wir,
quasi immer manövrierte Objekte umsonst, weil wir einfach ähm einen Fehlalarm vom richtigen Alarm nicht unterscheiden können. Die Genauigkeit der der Information lässt das nicht zu und mit dem Leser, mit dem Leser können wir da beikommen.
Und das ist so die, das ist so ein großer Erfolg jetzt aus dem Programm.
Wenn man immer ausweicht, äh, obwohl dann letzten Endes nichts ist, so ist so ein bisschen dieser bittere sorry äh Ansatz, aber das kostet ja Geld, ne? Also es kostet äh Livetime, weil man halt jedes Mal wieder irgendwelche Raketen aktivieren muss, Triebwerke.
Das kostet auch nervend.
Nerv.
Kostet auch Nerven, den.
Auch eine begrenzte Ressource, ja.
Und absolut und äh und es kostet sogar es kostet sogar Daten, denn manchmal müssen wir den Satelliten abschalten.
Wäre der manövriert und oder zumindest ihn,
Verbindung abschalten oder das Instrument ausschalten und na ja die die Gemeinden an Wissenschaftlern, die an diesen Daten hängen, die ist dann auch mitunter tausendköpfig und das ist dann auch ein nichts bemessener Verlust. Also,
Das kostet Ärger, Schweiß und Geld.
Und wenn wir da, wenn wir das äh hinbekommen, dann ähm lösen wir nicht nur ein Problem, sondern vielleicht ergibt sich sogar ein Markt. Warum.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man als Atelitenbetreiber interessiert ist, für gute äh Daten zu zahlen, ne? Wenn mir jemand etwas liefern kann.
Eine Qualität hat, wo wo mir ausgeschlossen werden kann, dass ich manövrieren muss und trotzdem alles in Ordnung ist. Ähm, das hätte einen Preis
und ähm das ist ähm das ist ein großer Wandel, der in den letzten zehn Jahren passiert ist. Wir haben immer gedacht,
dass diese ganze Wildraumüberwachung in die Hand von Staaten gehört.
Aber vielleicht tut sie das auch zum großen Teil, aber es gibt da drin Nischen, wie zum Beispiel Leser und genaue Informationen.
Die könnte durchaus mal einer privat liefern und damit ein Geschäft machen. Äh wenn wenn die Daten einen Mehrwert bieten und das tun sie, wenn sie ganz genau sind.
Nochmal so eine Nachfrage zu diesen Technologien, die du jetzt angesprochen hast, zunächst einmal diese Radarsysteme, also das Radar in Koblenz vom vom DLR heißt äh Gestra,
was macht das und das andere System, was du in Spanien angesprochen hast, hierzu anders? Also was inwiefern ist das so? Neuer Schritt.
Ähm das das System in Spanien, was auch mit der Hilfe von der ESA entwickelt worden ist.
Ähm überwacht äh das das heißt S drei Tenis Space to Williams, ein Trekkingrader.
Das ist in der Lage im Prinzip breitbandig, ähm einen großen Bereich im Himmel abzuscannen und neue Objekte zu entdecken und von denen die Bahn zu bestimmen. Also das könnte im Prinzip autark,
ein Katalog aufbauen und das ist das ist jetzt schon im Prinzip bereit in Betrieb zu treten. Also da sind wir sind wir mit fertig. Und das Gestra ähm das wird jetzt in Betrieb genommen, das ist der Schritt ist gerade passiert. In Koblenz.
Das äh hat im Prinzip zwei Modi, das kann das das Gleiche machen wie das spanische Rader, also neue Objekte aufspüren, sowas nennen wir das,
ohne ohne ohne Art von Vorinformationen einfach neue Objekte erkennen und aufspüren und im und einpflegen in die in die Liste der Objekte, die beobachtet werden.
Aber auch ähm bekannte Objekte gezielt nachverfolgen.
Also Trekking.
Trekking, nennen wir das. Ähm und dazu einen anderen Betriebsmodus gehen.
Und es ist auch so konzipiert, dass man im Prinzip mehrere Radare von diesen Typus äh zusammenschalten könnte, um entweder ein größeres Suchwelt zu erreichen oder,
höhere Intensität, also noch kleinere Objekte zu sehen.
Das das sind die beiden Konzepte. Auch das spanische Rade als skalierbar, das könnte man also auch noch erweitern, um ebenfalls das Suchfeld oder die Leistung ähm und damit die die Größe der Objekte nochmal voranzutreiben, die man damit sehen kann.
Wie muss man sich so die Kapazität von so einem äh Radar vorstellen, wenn das in so einem Survience-Modus ist, also man schaut sich das so wie
den ganzen Himmel gleichzeitig äh äh an, weil sozusagen Radarwellen in jede Richtung geworfen, die aus jeder Richtung reflektiert werden oder ist das ein sehr eingeschränkter Bereich, man muss
so schrittweise machen.
Ja, man darf sich das nicht so vorstellen, das hat keine mechanischen Schüssel.
Sondern das ist ein Planarantenne, ähm mit wo viele, viele hunderte Einzellanten draufgesetzt sind äh und die steht fest.
Und dann werden die Einzelantennen so zusammengeschaltet, dass man den den Raderstrahl elektronisch schwenken kann. Von der Einrichtung mit anderen in Lichtgeschwindigkei.
Mit einer mechanischen Schüssel, die man mühsam mit dem Motor bewegen muss, das sind meistens nur ein, zwei Grad pro Sekunde.
Mit diesem mit diesem ähm elektronischen Schwenken kann man im Prinzip den den Himmel überstreichen, in mit äh hin und her schwenken äh und sozusagen einen riesigen Suchbereich abtasten. Elektronisch,
innerhalb von Sekunden kann man mehr oder weniger einen gewaltigen Ausschnitt des Himmels abscannen, ja, wenn man so will,
Und das ist ein unglaublicher Vorteil, den diese Radare liefern und äh man kann im Prinzip einen Zaun zu erzählen, was auch tatsächlich Fans, ein Fans aufbauen, dem nichts entgeht, also äh der so schnell hin und her schwenkt,
alles was vom Strahl überstrichen wird, detektiert wird.
Mhm. Und äh wie klein können dann die Objekte sein, die von so einem Randar erfasst werden können?
Die amerikanischen Systeme sind jetzt in der Lage bis hinunter zu zehn Zentimeter, manchmal fünf Zentimeter, also Grenzgröße.
Und die unsere Systeme in Europa kommen nicht ganz so weit runter,
aber das ist nur eine Frage der Skalierung, ne. Die Technik ist da. Wenn man das jetzt noch aufskaliert, äh dann kommen wir da auch hin.
Skaliert durch eine größere Antenne oder mehr Systeme.
Mehr Systeme zusammenschalten oder größere Antenne. Die beiden Möglichkeiten hat man. Mhm. Läuft aus der Gleiche hinaus, man vergrößert die Zahl der Einzelrader, die Polanten, die da zusammengeschaltet werden,
Das muss man erreichen, das erhöht die Leistung,
wir sprechen wir sprechen äh hier über mehrere Megawatt an Leistungen, die da abgestrahlt werden. Das ist das, was man braucht, wenn man so kleine Objekte sehen will.
Da muss fragt man sich natürlich auch.
Äh muss man einen guten Vertrag haben mit dem mit dem Kraftwerk, aber man muss natürlich auch äh gucken, dass man's effektiv einsetzt.
Weiß man nämlich nach einer Zeit, welche Objekte es gibt, da muss man vielleicht nicht mehr unbedingt den Himmel so weitspurig abscannen,
denn dann würde man ja größtenteils nur ins Leere strahlen und den Weltraum aufheizen, da wo nichts ist. Dann könnte man dann im anderen Betriebsmodus gehen und sagen, okay, jetzt weiß ich mehr oder je weniger, was im Alter los ist. Ich kann mir jetzt berechnen, was zu welcher Zeit,
über das Radar drüber fliegt, äh welches Objekt und dann warte ich einfach auf das Objekt und verfolge, dass dann haargenau nach und ähm und und mache quasi eine Auffrischung,
Information durch 'ne erneute Messung und das reicht, das reicht dann für den Betrieb, ne? Da muss man nicht mehr unbedingt unbedingt den ganzen Himmel abscannen, systematisch oder das, oder man macht das nur noch einmal pro Woche, um zu gucken, ob inzwischen was Neues aufgetaucht ist und,
dann da kann man, das kann man durchaus ökonomischer machen. Da lernen wir jetzt gerade sehr viel äh über diese beiden Radere. Ähm was da so ein optimaler Betriebsmodus wäre.
Also es verbraucht in der Spitze zwei Komma acht Megawatt, wenn's die ganze Zeit angepowert äh wäre, aber muss es nicht die ganze Zeit voll durchpowern sozusagen.
Man muss es, ja, genau, man muss es nicht voll durchpowern, sondern verwenden, wenn man weiß, dass auch was da ist, was man denn denk.
Und der Leser äh hat sicherlich auch noch unten Fans den Namen, oder? Das Projekt.
Nee, das heißt einfach Leser.
Das heißt einfach nur Leser mit Anführungsstrichen vorn und hin wahrscheinlich. Wie spielt das da jetzt mit rein? Also äh das Ding ist ja dann noch in der Lage noch sehr viel kleinere Objekte äh zu erkennen oder.
Ein Leser, ein Leser Leser hat ja das hat den,
ist ja ein ganz ganz dünner Strahl. Also die Divagenz, also das, die das Aufweiten des Laserstrahls ist so gering, dass selbst in tausend Kilometern äh Entfernung ähm man vielleicht zehn Meter Strahldurchmesser hat, ja. Ähm,
Das heißt, man hatte dem Leserstrahl keine Chance, Objekte,
zu finden, äh indem man einfach mal hofft, dass was gerade ausgerechnet für diesen zehn Meter breiten Streif liegt, das das geht nicht. Das, das Leser ist eher dazu da,
schon bekannte Objekte ähm aufzugreifen, wenn sie auftauchen über den Horizont,
dann genau zu vermessen. Also bei dem Lesen, mit dem Leser verknüpfen wir die Chance, dass man,
dass man die Positionsbestimmung auf den auf den Dezimeter, also unterhalb von einem Meter Genauigkeit erreichen kann. Nur zum Vergleich beim beim Rader sind es äh einige Meter, wenn nicht sogar äh zehn Meter.
Das klingt jetzt so nach ähm Pfennig-Fuchserei, aber das macht einen gewaltigen Unterschied. Das macht einen gewaltigen Unterschie.
Okay, verstehe und jetzt ist es, sagen wir mal, auch in der in der Kombination natürlich interessant, weil wenn du sagst, die allermeisten Alarme sind Fehlame, das heißt, man hat halt so ein Objekt jetzt in der Datenbank, weil man meint, das mal gesehen zu haben und nach den Berechnungen müsste es halt jetzt irgendwie keine Ahnung, gerade irgendeiner Raumstation
gefährlich werden, würde man jetzt in dem Moment den Laser anschalten und sagen, jetzt gucken wir uns das Ding aber mal genauer an, was das wirklich ist. Und man sieht da nichts.
Und ist sich auch sicher, dass man an die richtige Stelle guckt, so dann könnte man diesen Fehlamen halt auch als solchen Er.
Genau. Das das ist die, das ist genau die Idee. Ähm wir bewerten quasi jeden Alarm durch eine genaue Lesermessung nochmal neu.
Und werden dann in allermeisten Fällen erkennen, dass man ähm im Prinzip sicher vorbeifliegt, weil das Objek,
man genau hinschaut, ähm, eigentlich nicht auf Kollisionskurs ist, sondern vielleicht zwanzig Meter vorbeifliegt.
Zwanzig Meter ist wenig. Zwanzig Meter würde viele nervös machen, aber wenn man wenn man die Bahn auf sagen wir mal einen halben Meter genau kennt.
Dann kann man sich auch leisten mit zwanzig Meter Abstand äh guten Gewissens aneinander vorbeizufliegen. Hat man zwanzig Meter Abstand prognostiziert, aber man kennt die Bahn nur auf zehn Meter genau,
dann würde man vielleicht lieber einen Ausweichmann überfliegen und das sind diese Fehlalarme, die ich meine. Ähm und diese, die diese Lesertechnologie, die könnte uns da helfen.
Aber die Lesertechnologie, wenn ich darf, ähm ein Blick in die Zukunft ähm wagen, die die liefert noch ein anderes, interessantes Potential, denn wir sprechen ja bisher nur über Kollisionen,
die sich vermeiden lassen, wenn einer der beiden eines der beiden Objekte ein Ausweichmanöver macht. Aber äh fünfundneunzig Prozent aller großen Objekte im All sind gar nicht aktiv.
Können gar kein Manöver machen. Wenn da zwei auf Kollisionskurs sind äh äh zwei nicht funktionsfähige Objekte auf Koalitionskurs sind, da können wir nur zuschauen und und warten bis es passiert.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, äh die Leserleistung ähm steigt noch weiter.
Und wir schaffen's, ähm, das, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen nach Science-Fiction, aber es ist durchaus im Bereich des Möglichen, schon in ein paar Jahren, dass man mit einem Leser ein Objekt vom Boden so stark bestrahlt.
Das ist sein Kurs leicht ändert.
Durch die eigentlich durch den äh Strahlungsdruck ähm ähm die Strahlung übt auch einen Druck aus. Ähm Photonprasseln quasi auf die auf die Oberfläche und üben im Puls aus und,
Der ist ganz schwach, da muss ich keine Dillusion machen.
Messbar, ich glaube, ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass das äh war das nicht mal so ein Effekt, den man,
äh Sonder irgendwann festgestellt hat, dass bestimmte Zahlen einfach nicht zusammenpassen wollten, bis man dann gemerkt hat, dass es,
Wärme aus einem Instrument hinten war, was quasi das Ding noch ein bisschen angeschoben hat, also so über die Zeit hat sich das halt so an äh gesammelt.
Auch so die Konzepte von Sonnensegeln, die von hinten mit Laser äh angeschoben werden.
Das sind die perfekten äh Beispiele, der Antennendruckprinzip, dass der Rückstoß äh durch das Absenden von Fotonen oder Strahlung aus der Antenne,
oder die die Reflexion in so einer Ultradünffolie, die man tatsächlich auch als die Sonne als Antrieb nimmt und wie im Segel dann den den Sonnenwind, den Strahlungsdruck gewissermaßen nutzt, um davon zu segeln.
Also du hast, du hast diese Idee vor zehn Jahren auch schon mal angesprochen, aber jetzt ist man sozusagen der Sache technologisch auch schon näher gekommen.
Ähm ja, es gibt äh jetzt bereits in Australien ein Leser, was diese Leistungsklasse hat und ähm äh da steht jetzt ein Experiment in Aussicht,
zum ersten Mal einen kleinen Satelliten damit leicht zu bewegen. Also wir sprechen wir sprechen hier von,
einem eine Geschwindigkeitsänderung von ein Millimeter pro Sekunde. Das ist nicht viel. Aber das reicht aus, wenn man's frühzeitig macht,
ähm eine Kollision womöglich zu verhindern und dann könnte man die Objekte im All managen.
Anstatt sie ja anstatt sie kollidieren zu lassen und vielleicht auch anstatt sie runter zu holen, vor allen Dingen die Objekte, die bereits im All hinterlassen worden sind. Wir sind noch nicht da, aber,
Das hat spielt gut zusammen mit der Strategie,
Objekte genauer zu vermessen, wo man ja auch einen Leser braucht. Ähm und wenn man diese Systeme sich noch weiterentwickeln, dann kann man sie auch womöglich in der Zukunft einsetzen, um Kollisionen zu verhindern.
Vor allem braucht man ja auch eine wirklich akkurate äh Echtzeitdatenbank aller Objekte. Existiert diese eigentlich in irgendeiner Form bereits?
Zurzeit existiert die in Amerika und in den USA äh so in Europa ist sie ein Aufbau? Echtzeit.
Kann man nicht verlangen. Kann man heute noch nicht erwarten. Also die Daten, wenn wir sie bekommen, sind die normalerweise zwölf Stunden alt,
dass es so lange dauert, dass eben von der Radermessung ähm Umwandlung in Orbit-Informationen bereitstellen über eine Webplattform und wir laden die runter, dann.
Ja gut, aber wenn man erstmal eine Bahn eine Position hat, dann kann man ja äh daraus auch eine Vorhersage treffen. Das ist das, was ich meine. Also es wäre ja schon möglich, aus diesen Daten quasi immer ein Ist-Zustand
der eigentlich sein müsste, der nicht unbedingt immer auf gemessenen Daten basiert, sondern eben auf vorhergemessenen und dann entsprechend äh per Vorhersage äh angepassten,
Position besteht, aber ich versuche mir das gerade so vorzustellen, wenn man jetzt also.
Sagen wir mal, wir haben jetzt so eine so eine so eine Batterie von diesen Superlasern, äh die in der Lage sind, alles so ein bisschen zu schieben.
Dann,
Dann würde man ja quasi auf so ein System hinauslaufen, wo man alles holistisch betrachtet und sagt, naja okay, also da würde es jetzt so wahrscheinlich in zwei Wochen zu einer Kollision kommen,
das Ding jetzt mal so einen Millimeter nach links schieben, dann ist es in zwei Wochen ein Kilometer woanders, als äh wir das uns jetzt eigentlich vorstellen,
So ja.
Ja es ist aber nicht so, dass man da durcheinander kommen würde, dass jeder da einzeln einzelne Objekte hin und her schiebt und dann keiner mehr den Überblick hat.
Ja, deswegen bräuchte man ja sozusagen eine gemeinsame äh äh Datenbank, wo man dann eben mathematisch äh die ganze Zeit drauf rumrechnet und sagt, okay, mit der Motivikation würde sich halt so äh ändern in der Gesamtdarstellung.
Das ist richtig. Ähm das Leser hilft uns dabei, denn mit dem Leser unter Genauigkeit, die sich da erzielen lässt.
Werden wir wahrscheinlich die Alarmzahlen soweit runterkriegen, dass wir nur noch wirklich die kritischen Fälle sehen,
diesen Aufwand des Bewegens, eines der Objektes nur noch ganz, ganz gezielt und ganz, ganz selten einsetzen müssen, nämlich da wo es wirklich notwendig ist. Ähm und deswegen gefällt mir das so gut, das gleiche System, Leser liefert die Genauigkeit, die wir brauchen,
damit das Ganze effizient ist und wir nicht ständig Objekte schieben müssen, aufgrund von Wagen, Prognosen,
sondern wir können ganz akkurat sagen, okay, der Fall ist jetzt wirklich kritisch und das wird nur wird vielleicht nur einmal pro Monat sein.
Die wirkliche Kollisionsrate, die wir haben ist ja eine Kollision in fünf Jahren so ungefähr. Das heißt, es passiert nicht so oft. Wir wir können's nur nicht genau noch genug erkennen.
Und das Leser kann es.
Und äh und dann kann es auch noch gezielt die die Gegenmaßnahme einleiten. Also mir gefällt das richtig gut. Wir sind wir sind sehr begeistert von diesem Ansatz. Ähm es muss funktionieren. Es muss nur funktionieren. Man darf nicht vergessen, wir müssen gewaltig viel,
Lichtleistung. Äh wir sprechen so von Kilowatt pro Quadratmeter, müssen wir durch die Atmosphäre bekommen.
Ähm und auf der Satellitenoberfläche muss die auch noch ankommen, damit sie ihre Wirkung entfalten kann. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch nicht so viel, denn die Solarleistung, das was die Sonne liefert,
ist eins Komma vier Kilowatt pro Quadratmeter. So, das ist die gleiche Leistung, die die wir von dem Leser erwarten
gezielt auf das Objekt gelenkt. Es ist quasi wie eine wie eine Sonnenlampe, die wir, die wir schwenken können. Äh das reicht schon aus, wenn man das, wenn man das über zwanzig, dreißig Minuten lang mit meinem Objekt macht, ähm dann kriegt man schon,
ein Ausweichmanöver zustande.
Also billiger als jetzt zwei Komma acht Megawatt von dem Radar auf jeden Fall. Mich erinnert das so ein bisschen an an Curling irgendwie. Ihr macht da so Weltraum-Curling, also man.
Wo so die ganzen Steine gerade so hingehen und dann nimmt man so ein Schrubber und dann so ah noch ein bisschen ich mein da wird ja im Prinzip auch das Eis kurz warm gemacht um äh ne äh um den Lauf ein bisschen zu ändern.
Wir haben auch mal drüber nachgedacht, ein Computerspiel, jetzt entwickeln, wo man das, wo man das ausprobiert, aber ähm da kommt noch was anderes dazu. Ich weiß nicht, ob Juristen ähm zuhören, aber.
Die werden vielleicht die Hände übern Kopf zusammenschlagen, denn natürlich gehört jedes Objekt irgendjemand im All, auch wenn es äh raumfahrtrechtlich gesehen ist es so, auch ein Schrottobjekt hat einen Eigentümer.
Der Eigentümer dem gehört nicht nur das Objekt, sondern der ist auch verantwortlich da.
Für mögliche Schäden, die von dem Objekt ausgehen. Und die würden das mitunter vielleicht gar nicht so gerne sehen, wenn jetzt einer anfängt, ähm über Laserfernsteuerung sozusagen seine, seine Objekte zu manifrieren. Ähm.
Ich habe mal deinen Wagen umgeparkt. Ja, hm.
Kann mir aber auch nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert, indem man sich von jedem erstmal schriftliches Einverständnis holt und einen komplizierten Vertrag schließt, das kann auch nicht gehen. Also da muss noch irgendwas passieren, dass man das, bevor man das systematisch einsetzt. Erstmal muss es funktionieren
muss auch die rechtliche Grundlage dafür geschaffen werden, dass das überhaupt.
Das klingt auch wieder nach einer interessanten, rechtlichen Frage und ja das ja das ist rechtlich ohnehin schwierig ist, das haben wir ja auch schon mal,
schon mal festgestellt, ähm trotz alledem so ein, so ein, so ein Körper, dem sozusagen vertraut wird, äh, entsprechende Korrekturen vorzunehmen,
die technologische Basis äh hat und wo dann quasi jeder mehr oder weniger vertraglich sagt, okay äh im Falle einer potenziellen Kollision hat,
dieser Rechtskörper die Freiheit hier einfach einzugreifen. So.
Das wäre der Traum Tim.
Wäre der Traum. Dafür bin ich zuständig. Als.
Wenn wenn wir ich verfolge manchmal selber diese Diskussion bei den Vereinten Nationen, Weltraumausschuss mit ähm.
Wir haben's seit über vierzig Jahren nicht geschafft, auch nur ein einzelnes Wort in den verstehen in den bestehenden Weltraumverträgen äh international zu ändern. Und seitdem ähm begnügen wir uns mit Richtlinien und nicht mehr mit Verträgen.
Und das zeigt schon, dass es sehr, sehr schwierig wird, ähm! Irgendwas verbindlich gerade zu rücken. Ich,
als Techniker, als Ingenieur denke ich mir immer, na ja
Ich beobachte ja jetzt schon mit Radar und mit ähm Leserobjekte im All und im Grunde genommen übe ich da ja auch schon Lichtdruck aus. Äh der ist allerdings kaum messbar, aber er ist.
Äh in der Praxis ist er tatsächlich da. Das sind da vielleicht nur Mikrometer pro Sekunde, aber er ist da. Ähm und da sagt keiner was, aber ähm da wird ein Jurist wahrscheinlich äh sagen, okay, da war ja auch nicht die Intention,
verbunden, was zu bewegen. Und ähm das macht vielleicht den Unterschied.
Jetzt äh,
weil äh wir haben über was hast du für eine Zahl genannt? Also sechzehntausend hatten wir vor zehn Jahren dreiundzwanzigtausend Objekte, die jetzt unterwegs sind,
paar davon dürften auch von Space X sein, unter anderem halt die Starling Konstellation, die jetzt Schritt für Schritt
ins Weltall entlassen wird und hier reden wir ja wirklich von ganz anderen Zahlen. Also es gibt glaube ich allein drei solche Internet aus dem Weltall.
Projekte eben Starling von Space, äh One Rap soll dann noch äh kommen und dieses Projekt ähm Korpa
Ich hab mal zusammengerechnet, also wenn die so auf ihre Maximalkonstellation kommen wären das allein nur diese drei Projekte neuntausendsechshundertfünfundzwanzig neue Satelliten, die noch mit dazu kommen,
Bei äh Spacis, die die einzigen sind, die bisher was gestartet haben, äh sind's davon allein viertausendvierhundertundneun und ähm.
Mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie viele bereits äh ich glaube so an die siebenhundert sind äh derzeit im All. Ein paar davon sind aber auch schon wieder,
zurückgekommen, wie zuverlässig hat das denn, also waren so diese ersten Versionen, die sozusagen Prototypen waren.
Hat das gut funktioniert, dass die äh alle wieder zurückgekommen sind, hat sich da irgendwas verbessert, habt ihr mit Space irgendwie mehr oder weniger Kontakt in dieser Hinsicht.
Ja, das ist, das ist tatsächlich die, die große Frage des äh dieses Jahrzehnts ist dieser radikale Wandel in der Raumfahrt. Vor zehn Jahren hatten wir davon keinen Schimmer, wenn mir das einer erzählt hätte. Da will einer zehntausende von Satellitenstaaten,
Das hätte ich nicht geglaubt, ja. Also aber jetzt Breitband aus dem All ist das große Thema.
Die Rechnung, die du gemacht hast, die habe ich auch aufgemacht, ja? Beere sind an die zehntausend Satelliten in wenigen Jahren, die gestartet werden sollen. Das ist mehr als die gesamte,
Geschichte der Menschheit, die die gesamte Raumfahrt bisher zusammen gestartet hat, das passiert jetzt in einigen wenigen Jahren und da spielt sich alles im Höhenbereich so zwischen fünfhundert und tausendzweihundert Kilometer ab, also auf engem Raum,
und du hast recht. Ähm bisher ist alles relativ gut gegangen. Es gab bei dem allerersten Space,
ungefähr drei ausgefallene Satelliten aus einem aus von sechsundsechzig die gestartet worden sind. Ähm,
aus den nachfolgenden Staats haben wir nicht festgestellt, dass Objekte ausgefallen sind. Äh es scheint also doch an an Robustheit äh dazu gewonnen zu haben und eine positive Entwicklung dabei,
Muss ja nicht alles alles so fürchterlich negativ sehen. Eine eine positive Entwicklung dabei ist, dass sich Spaßics entschlossen hat,
Großteil der Satelliten auf eine niedrige Bahn zu schicken von Anfang an. Also ursprünglich war geplant die Konstellationen tausendzweihundert Kilometer auszusetzen.
Jeder ausgefallene Sattel, die dort bedeutet, dass er auf alle Ewigkeit im All bleiben würde. Jetzt haben, jetzt fliegen sie ähm so ein fünfhundertfünfzig Kilometer Höhe,
da ein Satellit aus,
ist er nach zehn bis zwanzig Jahren aus dem allautomatisch verschwunden aufgrund der Restreibung, der in der Atmosphäre, die da noch vorhanden ist. Das ist ein das ist ein guter Schritt.
Aber du hast mich gefragt, hatten wir schon mal mit denen zu tun, ja? Wir hatten schon mit denen zu tun, denn fünfhundertfünfzig Kilometer,
Das ist auch die Höhe, wo einige unserer ISA-Satelliten unterwegs sind und es gab tatsächlich schon Kollisionswarnungen mit betriebenen Space X Ateliten und in dem Fall muss man sich eben äh mit den anderen Betreibern auseinandersetzen,
Noch sind wir es gewohnt, dass uns ein äh Stück Schrott entgegenkommt,
Klingt schlimm, aber es ist eigentlich ganz angenehm, denn dann wissen wir, was zu tun ist. Ähm das Rotstück wird nicht ausweichen können. Ähm wir können quasi einseitig,
entscheiden, was passieren soll und machen das auch äh und das verhält sich alles schön entlang der Bahnmechanik hat uns mit einem anderen betriebenen Satelliten zu tun,
Weiß man nicht, ändert er vorher nochmal seinen seine Bahn durch ein Manöver aus irgendeinem Grund,
oder hat er vielleicht sowieso vor auszuweichen, der müsste auch diese Kollisionswarnung bekommen und wenn er die Ausweichmanöver in die gleiche Richtung macht wie wir, dann ist es uns nicht geholfen
Also muss man mit dem Kontakt keinen Weg drum rum. Und ich muss sagen, in der westlichen Welt ähm.
Gibt es einen ganz guten Pragmatismus, man kennt sich, es gibt man weiß die E-Mail-Adressen nach einer Zeit, ähm und man kann sich austauschen und sich abstimmen, was da passiert.
Es klappt nicht immer reibungslos, aber im Großen und Ganzen funktioniert es, aber ich es gibt auch Satellitenbetreiber oder Satelliten von denen weiß ich gar nicht, wer das ist.
Ich habe keine Telefonnummer, es gibt kein Adressbuch, wo ich nachschlagen kann.
Es gibt keine internationale Satellitenregistrie, wo einfach,
also vielleicht sehe ich das jetzt einfach ein bisschen zu zu einfach und zu romantisch, aber meine Vorstellung wäre davon, wenn man was ins All setzt,
dann gibt's irgendwo 'ne Datenbank, wo da eine ID drinsteht
was das ist und ja, so eine, so eine, so eine selbstgenerierte äh im gesamten Weltall eindeutige ID, die einfach publiziert wird und dann steht da eine E-Mail-Adresse und eine Telefonnummer dran.
Ist nicht so.
Ja, das sollte jeder, du hast, du hast einen absolut gesunden Menschenverstand und oder euch hat er das so so erwartet, als ich mit dem Thema angefangen habe und das ist uns vielleicht erwartet, dass auch viele Hörer, aber das ist absolut nicht so. Es ist leider nicht so, es ist jeder angehalten,
sein Objekt zu registrieren. Ähm bei den Vereinten Nationen, aber das machen nicht alle.
Ähm und registrieren heißt auch nicht, dass man da ähm irgendwie einen operationellen Kontaktdaten hinterlässt, sondern das heißt nur, okay, dieses Objekt gehört,
gehört was.
Briefkastenfirma auf den Kyman Island.
Ja oder manchmal ist es nur das Land, ja, was aus dem der Betrieb stattfindet, nur auf welcher Bahn das ist. Also das, das reicht nicht. Ähm für den Betrieb braucht man noch viel, viel mehr und.
Wir fangen jetzt an solche Netzwerke unterpragmatisch Satellitenbetreibern aufzubauen ähm mit mit dem Austausch
aber es es wird nie eine Verpflichtung geben sich daran zu beteiligen, sondern das ist dann alles freiwillig. Ähm aber ich erlebe genug Pragmatismus, dass da genug Leute mitmachen. Aber ihr macht noch was anderes Sorge, weil die,
dieser Aufwand, der vergrößert sich immer weiter, ne? Also wir müssen ja jetzt schon zwei, dreiköpfiges Team von Experten beschäftigen, die nur rund um die.
Diese Kollisionswarnung beobachten, wenn die jetzt auch noch ständig telefonieren müssen, um sich mit Leuten mit anderen Betreibern abzustimmen, dann wird das nicht mehr handelbar,
ähm und außerdem muss man sich mal angucken, wie das in anderen Branchen gehandelt wird. Ich gucke mir da gerne den Flugverkehr an.
Ja ähm da gibt es Flugpläne, da gibt es Flight Levels, ja, weil da wird von vornherein ein Abstand ähm eingepflegt in das ganze Flugsystem. Da gibt es Flight Roules, wo wo es heißt, Turnleft äh und vor allen Dingen gibt es,
Geräte an Bord, äh, der Flugzeuge, die sich untereinander abstimmen, ohne dass der Pilot.
Da abgelenkt wird oder irgendwie in einer Brandpower reinstecken muss, sondern die die beiden Flugzeuge, die aufeinander zukommen, handeln im Prinzip untereinander aus.
Was der beste Ausweg ist, um eine Kollision zu verhindern und äh der Pilot kriegt dann nur noch das Ergebnis mitgeteilt. Turnleft, ja. Ähm das sollte man im einundzwanzigsten Jahrhundert von der Raumfahrt vielleicht auch erwarten.
Na gut, aber ich meine, bei der Luftfahrt ist ja meistens so alles was fliegt, das ist ja auch meistens noch im Betrieb.
Das ist richtig, ja, das wäre schlimm, wenn das wieder weil es so so ja.
Also so so Zombieflugzeuge, wenn sie gibt, sind ja nicht so lange unterwegs, das lässt sich ja dann in Bildern auch nicht so ohne Weiteres machen.
Ja. Das ist richtig. Ähm man muss immer den den Raumfahrtschrott muss man immer ausweichen können, aber was ich meine mit Space X und den ganzen Großkonstellationen.
Haben wir jetzt,
ja zwanzig Prozent aller Kollisionswarnungen haben wir es eben nicht mehr mit Straumstrott, sondern mit einem aktiven Satelliten zu tun. Und da kommt das Thema zum Tragen. Kann man sich nicht da auch intelligenter vernetzen.
Dann sagen viele, ja aber da brauchen wir doch erstmal Regeln. Oder da müsste erstmal der Gesetzgeber Vorfahrtsregeln einführen sozusagen,
Das stimmt zwar, aber ähm ich denke ich denke, dass man trotzdem technisch voranschreiten kann, ähm denn wenn einmal die Information ausgetauscht wird.
Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich habe sowieso vor zu manövrieren oder ich kann grad nicht manifrieren oder sagen wir mal ähm oder sagen wir mal, ich kann überhaupt nicht manövrieren, weil ich überhaupt keinen Motor an Bord habe, das wäre schon mal ein Anfang. Ähm,
zum Beispiel, weil ich nur ein Cube satt bin äh mit zehn Zentimeter Durchmesser ohne Motor. Also das, das wäre schon mal ein Anfang und.
Wenn man ehrlich ist und das mit dem Autoverkehr vergleicht, da gibt es zwar Regeln,
aber im großen Teil lässt man sich davon leiten, was einem Google Maps sagt, ja. Also und das ist ja auch eine eine technische Lösung äh vor allen Dingen, die Daten zusammenführt. Und damit fängt es meiner Meinung nach an.
Kennt man ja auch schon Leute, die da irgendwo irgendwelche Brücken runtergefallen sind, bei den guten Möps gesagt hat, fahr da mal lang, aber es war halt äh noch gar nicht fertig gebaut. Hm, tja, wie viele Leute müssten sich denn an so einen Regelberg halten, damit's irgendwie funktioniert.
Ist ja so ein bisschen wie beim Impfen, ne? Also.
Ah ja, guter Vergleich, ja ja genau ähm richtig, also.
Es wird immer Impfgegner geben, auch bei uns. Ähm das ist klar, es es wird bei einigen heißen, nein, wir lassen uns nicht von einem internationalen,
Netzwerk, auch wenn das gar nicht weisungsbefugt ist, sondern immer auf Freiwilligkeit beruhen wird, aber diese einige werden immer sagen,
nee, da machen wir nicht mit, das ist eine Einschränkung unserer Autonomie, denn äh die Raumfahrtgesetzgebung, die gibt einem tatsächlich ja viel Freiheiten, die sagt.
Jeder darf den Weltraum nutzen.
Solange er den die Freiheit des anderen nicht einschränkt und das ist sehr weit dehnbar diese Interpretation und da werden sich einige darauf berufen und und nicht mitmachen, aber ich glaube ähm in der Zukunft wird's ja so sein, dass ohnehin,
tausende von Satelliten in der Hand von wenigen Leuten sind und damit hätte schon mal schon mal ein Großteil erschlagen.
Und wenn man die, wenn man die zumindest zusammenbindet, ja, in so einem Netzwerk, das wäre schon mal geholfen. Und äh wir haben Kontakte zu Space und die sind dann sowas durchaus interessiert.
Du hast gerade erwähnt, diese ähm Cubesatz, diese kleinen Satelliten, die kommen ja auch immer mehr in Mode, weil's halt ähm günstige Extrapilot ist, die noch irgendwo zu haben war. Es gibt mittlerweile eine ganze Menge
universitäre Forschungsprojekte, die diese Gelegenheit nutzen und dadurch, dass halt die Elektronik et cetera so günstig geworden ist, dass man das machen kann,
wird's halt auch viel gemacht, aber das heißt ja, es haben noch mehr potentielle Ausfallware unterwegs, es sind die ein großes, großer Teil des Problems.
Die waren immer die Prügelknaben, der Prölematik, weil sie zu Beginn dieser Cubesat ähm Entwicklung.
Sind sie oft auf Bahnen gelandet, wo sie nicht hätten sein sollen. Ähm sie sind oft mit einem größeren Satelliten in dem gleichen Staat mitgestartet.
Und der Größe Satellit gibt dann die Bahn vor, wo wo es lang geht und die der Kleine ist dann einfach auf der gleichen Bahn ausgesetzt worden,
viel zu hoch oft. Äh, der große Satellit hat aber einen Motor, mit dem er sich am Ende wieder selber entsorgen kann hoffentlich und der der Cube seit eben nicht. Und so waren in der Vergangenheit die Cubes Urs oft die Prügelknaben ähm das hat sich geändert, denn,
Dadurch, dass es jetzt mehr Kübsatz gibt.
Ähm lohnt es sich, eine Rakete im Prinzip damit komplett aufzufüllen und einen Start zu machen, nur mit Clubsatz. Und dann kann man natürlich von vornherein eine Höhe ansteuern, äh die dann nicht mehr kritisch ist. Also zum am liebsten haben wir es unterhalb der Raumstation.
Dass die also auch nicht mehr durch die Höhe der Raumstation wandern ähm und oft,
funktioniert ja so ein Cubes hat auch nicht länger als äh ein, zwei Jahre, das ist so demissionsdauer und ähm dann muss er auch nicht in Orbit sein, wo er, wo er zig Jahre im All ist und dann reicht es vielleicht in vierhundert Kilometer Höhe
ausgesetzt zu werden und oft werden die auch direkt aus der Raumstation rausgelassen, das geht heute auch. Werden also mit dem Transport da hochgebracht und dann von den Astronauten,
gewissermaßen rausgeschmissen äh und äh leben dann als Cubesat alleine weiter und das reicht oft, um um die Experimente durchzuführen. Die Cupstadt sind heute nicht mehr so,
so das Schreckgespenst, weil sie sich von vornherein auf günstigen Orbits ausgesetzt werden. Wir machen uns eher Sorgen um so die Satellitenklasse hundert Kilogramm eine Tonne,
die in Höhen fliegen wo das Entsorgen mit einem mit dem eigenen Bordmotor unbedingt funktionieren muss.
Wenn nicht, äh, bleiben Sie eben über Jahrhunderte im Alter, das die, das sind die, die uns große Sorgen machen.
Also die tausendzweihundert Kilometer Bereiche zum Beisp.
Ja, ja. Ja, ja, ganz sensitiv, ja.
Wir hatten letztes Mal auch bei äh noch über Geostationäre Satelliten gesprochen, das ist ja nochmal eine andere Geschichte, weil da kann man halt nicht irgendwo hinfliegen, wo man dann verglüht, sondern da gibt's ja quasi nur diese Parkpositionen.
Wie hat sich das in dem Segment denn er entwickelt.
Positiv. Positiv. Ähm das äh da haben wir beobachtet, dass heute quasi alle.
Alle Satellitenbetreiber ihr Objekt ordnungsgemäß auf der sogenannten Friedhofsbahn entsorgen. Die liegt nochmal vierhundert Kilometer weiter draußen.
Das war vor zehn Jahren noch nicht ganz so, aber heute passiert das und es ist aber so, dass sich das Gewicht verschoben hat.
Ähm die Kommerzialisierung, die haben wir immer so im Geo, in diesem gestationären Ring vorhergesagt. Aber das hat sich äh komplett gewandelt. Ähm der Verkehr im Geo,
hat nicht weiter zugenommen. Ähm es sind werden so ungefähr sechzehn Satelliten pro Jahr außer Dienst gestellt und dann auch ersetzt.
Manchmal auch nicht mehr ersetzt. Ähm und diese sechzehn, die werden dann auch ordnungsgemäß entsorgt heute. Das ist eine positive Entwicklung.
Das Problem hat sich jetzt verlagert in den Leo. In dem äh in dem niedrigen Erdorbitz, ähm wo auch die Kollision stattgefunden haben, wo die,
Dichte an Objekten, noch viel größer ist, viel dichter bepackt und wo jetzt diese Großkonstellation noch dazu kommen,
hier liegt die Erfolgsrate immer noch nur noch bei sechzig oder siebzig Prozent des Entsorgens nach dem Betrieb.
Dass es viel, viel kritischer momentan als die EG-Städte nähering, ne.
Ja, das ist zu viel, ne?
Viel zu viel, viel zu viel sechzig Prozent heißt, vierzig Prozent stranden.
Vierzig Prozent von von hundert Satelliten, die heute gestartet werden, heißt vierzig Satelliten, das ist viel zu viel, die jedes Jahr strangen,
vierzig Satelliten von tausend Satelliten, die vielleicht in zwei Jahren jedes Jahr gestartet werden ist absolut nicht akzeptabel. Und deswegen brauchen wir sowas wie den TÜV.
Auch für Raumfahrzeuge, aber auch.
Die Technik, die ähm sozusagen den Satelliten robust macht und auch äh in die Lage versetzt, autonom äh sich zu entsorgen und auch den Treibstoff ins Seil zu entlassen.
Oder man ruft die Müllabfuhr. Darüber hatten wir letztes Mal auch so perspektivisch äh gesprochen, wie schön's doch äh wäre, wenn es Methoden gäbe
einfach da hochzufahren und zu sagen, okay, das passt uns jetzt hier gerade mal nicht äh rein, äh den nehmen wir jetzt mal lieber aus dem Ohrbit äh raus, bevor er dann noch größeren Schaden anrichtet,
also das Wegschießen oder wegwärmen, kleinster äh Objekte, haben wir jetzt schon gesehen, damit kann man zumindest das Problem bisschen in den Griff kriegen.
Aber es gibt ja noch richtig großes Zeug äh da draußen, unter anderem parkt da noch dieser Bus, äh der Invisad Satellit, der ja irgendwann mal ausgefallen ist, einer der größten,
Satelliten glaube ich überhaupt, äh die derzeit so rumcruisen und warten eigentlich nur darauf, irgendwann mal von irgendwas beschossen zu werden.
Oder selber äh gegebenenfalls noch auszufallen. Ähm gibt's denn da Fortschritte? Also.
Wird denn jetzt über solche Maßnahmen wirklich nachgedacht?
Da gibt es wirklich Fortschritte. Wir haben innerhalb der Isar, in dem Raumfahrtsicherheitsprogramm, haben wir vor im Jahr zweitausendfünfundzwanzig.
Erstmalig so eine Demonstration durchzuführen. Mit Demonstrationen meine ich, dass tatsächlich ein Schrottobjekt aus dem All entfernt wird. Nämlich eins, was der Isar gehört und was bereits heute schon während wir sprechen im All vorhanden ist.
Mhm. Welches ist das?
Das ist ein ähm Adapter einer einer einer europäischen Rakete. Äh Vespa heißt dieser Adapter. Ähm muss man sich vorstellen, wie so ein wie so ein Rollkegel, also ein kegelförmiges Objekt.
Mit zwei Meter Durchmesser, auf dem im Prinzip mal ein Satelliten gesessen hat, äh, während des Staats und diese.
Wegen der Form sozusagen, nur wegen dieser Wespenform.
Gute Frage, nicht dich dieses bestimmten Abkürzungen, die ich jetzt nicht weiß.
Mit der Garantie.
Sieht ein bisschen anders aus als die Westbahn ist, also ist auch nicht himmelblau, also.
Klang eben so tailliert, deswegen dachte ich da.
Ist ja der Grund, warum die Vespa Vespa halt.
Er sieht, da ist aber trotzdem formschön. Äh
ist schwarz äh und ähm besteht aus ähm Kohlefaser verstärktem Kunststoff, ein bisschen Metall. Wiegt hundert Kilogramm. Also es ist nichts ist schon ein ordentliches äh ordentliches Ding.
Und fliegt in siebenhundert Kilometer Höhe und würde ohne Eingreifen mehrere Jahrzehnte im All bleiben. Nicht nicht akzeptabel,
Und es ist ein fantastisches Übungsobjekt, ähm denn es ist semetrisch.
Ähm es wir kennen es gut, es gehört uns, das heißt, wir müssen mit niemand mühsam Vertrag aushandeln und,
es hat auch äh so ein bisschen so die Größe und den Orbit
von vielen von diesen Satelliten in der Zukunft gestartet werden und dann das bedeutet, dass wenn wir das erfolgreich demonstrieren mit diesem Adapter, dann ist es auch glaubhaft, dass wir das mit mit einem von diesen ähm zukünftigen Satelliten,
schaffen können, wenn die mal stranden, ne? Ähm,
und das äh ist nicht nur Ankündigung, sondern wir unterschreiben tatsächlich einen Vertrag äh nächsten Monat, im November mit mit einer Schweizer Firma.
Diese Mission für uns durchführen sollen. Clear Space ist es noch nie,
so etwas gemacht worden und es ist ein großer Aufwand, den wir, den wir betreiben, ja, als,
sich an einen nicht funktionsfähiges, unkontrolliertes Objekt anzunähern, von den wir die Taumelrate noch nicht genau kennen, ja? Ähm.
Wollte ich gerade fragen, weil das ja dann ein nicht ganz unerheblicher äh Teil der Komplexität, wenn das Ding permanent um sich äh herum rotiert,
dann ist sehr schwer zu greifen, was hat ja auch extreme kinetische Kräfte dadurch. Was ist denn da der Ansatz? Also wie will man denn da jetzt ran? Wirft man an Netz rüber oder macht man das mit Lebstoff oder wird er mit Laser äh erstmal eingeschüchtert.
Also die, die Firma hat die Idee, ein ein Greifersystem zu benutzen, was aus vier Armen besteht,
zu sagen an jeder Ecke des Raumfahrzeugs ist ein Arm angebracht. Ähm diese Arme sind mehrere Meter lang und die würden dieses Objekt gewissermaßen umschließen, also so quasi umarmen,
aus vier Richtungen ähm umschließen und zwar ist die Idee, dass man es,
Umschlossen hat, bevor man es berührt. Äh denn du weißt ja, wenn im All irgendwie einen Kontakt herstellt und eine Berührung, dann gibt es Wort einen Impulsübertrag und das driftet in die andere Richtung weg und das äh,
immer mal beobachtet, wie.
Astronauten vom Shuttle äh versucht haben, Satelliten einzufangen, die haben da Stunden gebraucht, ja? Weil die Dynamik so extrem extrem komplex ist. Ähm fast einer an, dann driftet der in die andere Richtung und so weiter. Da mussten am Ende mehrere Astronauten mithelfen,
Problem ist robotisch natürlich noch viel schwerer in den Griff zu kriegen. Deswegen die Lösung erst umklammern,
und dann langsam an sich ziehen, ähm bis die Taubenbewegung aufgehört hat, dann äh kann man es äh zentrieren,
Und dann wird es äh übt, wird ein Prinzip Motor ähm betrieben an Bord, äh der das Raumfahrzeug und das eingefangene Objekt gemeinsam,
nach unten bewegt und diese Klammermethode hat noch einen weiteren Vorteil, man kann das Objekt nämlich wieder freilassen.
Wieder öffnen. Das Objekt wird freigegeben äh und das zum Beispiel auf einem Orbit in vielleicht nur dreihundert Kilometer Höhe und dann äh hat man's,
ist man's in ein paar Wochen los, die Atmosphäre mit ihrer Bremswirkung macht den Rest aber das Vehikel kann dann nochmal nach oben fliegen und sie vielleicht noch ein zweites greifen, ne? Also das ist die, das ist die Idee,
Wir werden's jetzt erstmal mit nur mit einem Objekt ausprobieren. Die Herausforderung ist schon groß genug. Und äh ja, zweitausendfünfundzwanzig soll es soweit sein.
Wie viel also wie viel Treibstoffe das denn mit sich äh führen. Also kann es schon sein, dass wenn das jetzt gelingt, dass dann noch,
Treibstoff übrig wäre, man könnte noch eine Folgemission machen und man hat erstmal nur nicht mehr vor oder beschränkt man das von vornherein schon und sagt.
Nee, wir müssen das in dem Fall von vornherein von vornherein uns auf das Beschränken, denn,
wir haben nur eins, die Esa ähm ist eine sehr saubere Raumfahrtorganisation mit wenig Schrottobjekten. Ähm und es muss ist ja auch so, äh wir können nicht beliebig zwei Objekte auswählen, sondern die müssen.
Energetisch gesehen eine gewisse Nähe haben. Also die müssen auf auf ähnlichen Bahnen unterwegs sein.
Und diese Konstellation können wir mit Eserobjekten nicht bieten. Ähm, dass wir eher was für 'ne Konstellation.
Eine Konstellation, wo ähm Objekte, wie auf der Perlenschnur hintereinander in der gleichen Ebene aufgereizt sind.
Die lasst sich viel, viel besser bedienen mit solchen äh Abräummissionen.
Also sowas wie Iridium oder GPS-Satelliten oder Navigationssysteme im Allgemeinen oder eben Starlink, was wir äh vorhin angesprochen haben. Mhm.
Sogar soweit gehen, dass man ähm das Aufräumen wie Hickel von vornherein mit mit sechsundsechzig von diesem Styling Satelliten einschießt auf diese Bahn.
Wenn zum Beispiel eine Bahnebene aufgefüllt wird mit mehr und mehr Satelliten,
und inzwischen schon ein, zwei in diesem Orbit auf ausgefallen sind, dann macht man bei diesem nachfolgenden Start in die gleiche Bahn, eben nimmt man eben das Aufräumvehikel mit und spart dann nochmal viele viele Kosten beim Start, ne.
Das ist angedacht, ja? Da und da deswegen diese.
Also jetzt für die gezielte Aktion oder sozusagen so von vornherein schon mal immer gleich noch die Müllabfuhr mitschicken, falls man sie mal später braucht.
Na ja, wir muss da so sagen, wir wir können ja Space nicht vorschreiben.
Aus der Perspektive von SpaceX so, ich meine das wäre dann sozusagen auch nochmal so eine so eine Absicherung.
Ja, für fürs Basics wäre das, wäre das interessant, wenn es sowas gibt, das muss natürlich, das muss natürlich ähm zu vertretbaren Preisen passieren, ähm denn momentan,
gibt es Weltraumrecht, nicht irgend nicht generiert kein Incentive oder Zwang sowas zu tun, ne. Das muss man muss man sich im Klaren sein. Heute gibt es noch kein.
Kniff ähm der jemand dazu zwingt, so einen Service auch zu bezahlen. Ähm da da m.
So ein bisschen den Eindruck und das gilt wahrscheinlich für Space noch mehr als für alle anderen. Ähm,
das bisher war das, was so im All stattfand, so ein bisschen, na ja okay, das so Science und Technologie. Was haben wir denn damit zu tun?
Aber gerade mit Starlink kam ja dann auch schon dieser dieser Aspekt mit, oh jetzt wird also hier die Lichtverschmutzung.
Nochmal so richtig angeheizt, so ich weiß, dass mittlerweile Maßnahmen begriffen worden, dass das äh Problem nicht mehr so ganz äh da ist, aber es wird sich halt auch nicht komplett verhindern lassen, dass diese große Zahl an Satelliten in zunehmendem Maße im Blick aufs Eil verstellt
Und das tut sie ja nicht nur gegenüber,
den Astronom, sondern gewisser Hinsicht wird es dann auch schon als Umweltverschmutzung wahrgenommen. Und natürlich könnte auch so eine erhöhte Dichte und dieses Problem,
dieses Problem, das man unter Umständen der Schuldige wird äh die ganze Raumfahrt äh gekillt zu haben,
auch ein Imageproblem sein. Ich will nur darauf hinaus, dass das sozusagen in Zukunft durchaus auch ein Incentive sein kann, dass man hier einen Imageverlust äh vorbeugen,
müsste unter Umständen.
Da hast du völlig recht. Und äh wir wir interpretieren auch so manche Reaktionen in die Richtung, dass man durchaus,
durchaus auf keinen Fall derjenige sein will, der der die Raumfahrt eines Tages abwirkt und ähm es könnte sich dadurch dadurch äh auch schon allein einen Markt äh ergeben.
Wir haben ähm dieser Firma Clears Base auch nicht zu viele Vorgaben gemacht. Wir haben gesagt, ähm,
sucht euch ein Objekt aus, wo ihr glaubt, dass es so die Größenordnung hat, dass es repräsentativ ist für einen zukünftigen Markt, ja? Also richtet die ganze Mission äh so aus, dass es später auch auf eigenen Füßen steht, denn,
Wir glauben nicht, dass es der Steuerzahler ist, der der dauerhaft äh solche Missionen zahlen sollte. Natürlich würden wir gerne den N-Visat äh auch noch mit mit herunterholen, aber,
am Ende sind es auch nicht die die öffentlichen Missionen, die so den Großteil der Verschmutzung darstellen werden in ein paar Jahrzehnten. Also richtet euch nach dem Markt aus, aber wo soll dieser Markt herkommen?
Natürlich wird es die Imagekampagnen geben, die du genannt hast, dass einer allein aus aus eigenen Einsicht sozusagen ähm handeln will.
Aber ich glaube das reicht nicht. Also wir wir brauchen wir brauchen auch ähm ein Incentive, der durch den Gesetzgeber kommt und ich könnte mir zum Beispiel vorstellen.
Dass in zukünftigen Raumfahrtgesetzen national, die gibt es ja, national eben Betreiber äh verpflichtet werden.
Ihr Objekt mit so einem Service abzuholen, wenn sie es eben nicht aus eigenen Mitteln geschafft haben, das zu entsorgen. Und.
Die Gesetzgeber, wenn man mit denen spricht, dann sagen die, na ja, momentan würden wir das uns noch nicht trauen zu schreiben, ähm das würde alle Satellitenbetreiber aus dem Land vergraulen und alle würden,
Islands äh für die Raumfahrt verschwinden, wo solche Vorgaben nicht gemacht werden.
Ähm es sei denn, es wird mal demonstriert, dass es funktioniert und das ist auch für einen vernünftigen Preis funktioniert. Ähm.
Und das ist die Aufgabe einer Raumfahrtagentur wie die Esa, genau das zu machen, diesen diesen Zyklus zu durchbrechen und zu zeigen, ja, es geht und es geht vielleicht sogar für einen einstelligen Millionenbetrag ähm dann,
kann man ähm dann kann man das ähm ähm auch besseren Gewissens in so einem Gesetz vorsehen und dann hat man gleich zwei Effekte. A,
Satellitenbetreiber wird peinlich genau darauf achten, dass seine Mission ähm eben nicht strandet, um um solche Kosten zu vermeiden,
B, wenn sie doch strandet, dann hat man eben den Markt für das aktive Abholen. Das wäre die Traumlösung. Wenn man nicht so schnell sehen, aber sagen wir mal so, die die Gesetzgebung.
Kommt immer nach der Technik, das haben wir beobachtet. Erst müssen die Lösungen gezeigt werden. Dann folgt die Gesetzgebung und das ist der Schritt, den wir jetzt machen.
Macht Jani auch Sinn, also ein Gesetz zu machen und auf Basis und äh Traumtechnik, die sich am Ende nicht bewähren kann. Das hat ja irgendwie keinen Sinn. Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das jetzt äh schon implizit äh mitgemeint hast. Ähm ich glaube, wir hatten letztes Mal auch so grob über die Idee eines Pfandsystems äh nachgedacht und vielleicht ein bisschen weiter gedacht, könnte man ja auch sagen, okay. Was ist, wenn jetzt quasi jeder.
Der eine Paylot ins All bringt für jedes Kilogramm ein bestimmten Betrag in einen Fonds leg.
So in einen Rückholfond und dann gibt's halt einen Preis für wenn was aus dem All geholt werden soll für jedes Kilo, was quasi nicht selber runtergekommen ist. Ja, man kriegt halt sozusagen in dem Moment, wo man selber äh,
erfolgreich wieder die orbitiert hat oder wie sagt man dazu? Ja, dann kriegt man sozusagen ein Teil davon auch wieder.
Aber wenn nicht, dann ist sozusagen die Kohle, die Bounty für äh äh Leute, die halt da so Kopfgeldjäger mäßig im äh All unterwegs sind und dann eben wie Clear Space zum Beispiel dafür sorgen, dass es dann halt zurück.
Ja, das ist dann so wie so ein CO zwei Zertifikatehandel, ne?
Ja vielleicht auch ein ähnlicher Vergleich.
Das ist das ist eine eine andere, sehr denkbare Lösung, aber das erfordert dann,
erfordert dann wieder rechtlich gesehen all irgendwie 'n internationalen, funktionierenden Mechanismus, wo ich jetzt in den letzten zehn Jahren skeptischer geworden bin, dass das sowas, dass dass das was ich gelernt habe,
als in der IFA-Ingenieur, dass man da nicht mal so hinspazieren kann äh und denen erzählen kann, wie wie sie ihre Gesetze schreiben müssen.
Na schon klar, aber ich meine, das gab's auch bei den Banken irgendwann mal nicht so, ne? Und äh mittlerweile ist es halt so, dass es irgendwie einen Fonds gibt, der eben pleitegehende Banken dann am Ende zumindest den Kunden noch irgendwas äh garantiert, was übrig bleibt.
Aber wie dir der Gedanke gefällt mir unglaublich gut, äh dass über ein Pfandsystem ähm zu lösen. Ähm ich wir betrachten und das hat sich auch so ein bisschen in den letzten zehn Jahren gewandelt.
Setzt sich mehr und mehr so eine Betrachtungsweise durch, dass die den Raum als eine Ressource wahrzunehmen,
wie ganz ähnlich wie beim Klima, ja? Also wo es eben eine gewisse Kapazität nur noch da ist, zum Beispiel CO zwei aufzunehmen, haben wir auch eine gewisse Kapazität noch Objekte aufzunehmen.
Ähm aber das ist eine Ressource, die nicht gemeinsam verwaltet wird, sondern jeder hat,
das Recht, diese zu nutzen, wie er will, ohne auf die Grenzen zu achten. Keiner gibt eine Grenze vor. Ähm wir äh mir ist aber aufgefallen.
Dass wir auch eine andere global genutzte Ressource haben, die wir gemeinsam verwalten. Und das ist das Frequenzspektrum.
Jeder, der ein Satellit startet, äh will auch mit dem kommunizieren. Muss also eine Stück von dem Frequenzband benutzen,
wenn das das gleiche Frequenzband von jemand anders benutzt wird, dann gibt es Indiferenzen und das Ganze funktioniert nicht mehr. Das heißt, die haben sich dann aus Eigeninteresse ähm global zusammengeschlossen, äh internationale,
ITU, International Telecommunications Union, ein UN-Gremium ähm und auch wenn es keine Pflicht gibt.
Da mitzuwirken, machen das alle.
Weil natürlich jeder vernünftig seine Mission fliegen will und nicht gestört werden will, keine Differenzen haben will und Planungssicherheit haben will, dass wir nicht was in vier Jahren starte, mit dem Frequenzband, dass das nicht schon jemand anders besetzt hat, macht es Sinn.
Sich auch wenn die Ressource frei verfügbar ist, sie trotzdem gemeinsam,
managend sozusagen, sich abzusprechen, was hast du für einen Bedarf? Ähm aha, du willst im Jahr zweitausendvierundzwanzig fliegen, in der Höhe mit der Frequenz, okay und du und du und du und wenn's sich, wenn's eben kollidiert, dann muss man eben handeln.
Und auseinander Lösungen handeln, sich einschränken mit dem Frequenzband oder später fliegen oder
oder vielleicht weniger Raumfahrzeuge oder dem anderen Frequenzen abkaufen, ja. Also das das warum das das müssen wir auch für die Nutzung äh des Raumes als,
Platzressource sozusagen auch hinkriegen. Das ist ein Gedanke, den wir jetzt sehr, sehr stark verfolgen.
Und das könnte man vielleicht sogar verknüpfen. Warum nicht mit dem mit dem Frequenz,
Aushandeln nicht auch sozusagen, die die Ressourcen Raum gleich mitverwalten. Ähm.
Dass man sich auch so ein Orbit äh quasi mietet.
Mietet oder abspricht. Ähm zum Beispiel Schau, ich gehe jetzt mit meinen zwanzig Satelliten in fünf Jahren dahin ähm spricht irgendwas dagegen, ja? Ähm,
Sagt einer, ja, da wollte ich auch hin und da sagt man, okay, dann dann gehe ich halt nochmal zehn Kilometer höher oder so, ja? Ähm so stehe ich mir das so funktioniert das bei den Frequenzen tatsächlich, also da.
Würde ja fast meinen, dass es auch heute schon so funktionieren müsste eigentlich, ne? Ich meine, was ist wenn wenn Starlink irgendwie von bestimmten Höhen ausgeht und dann launcht sich irgendjemand einfach in diesen Bereich rein.
Wäre absolut legal heute, ja?
Ja, aber nicht gerade besonders praktisch.
Nein, aber es ist ja auch so, ähm was ist, wer hat denn gesagt, dass Base X sozusagen diese Höhenschale fünfhundertfünfzig Kilometer komplett.
Alleine nutzen darf oder sozusagen eine Verdrängungsnutzung ist es ja schon fast äh betreiben kann. Das ist ja auch in die abgesprochen worden. Das heißt, da da fehlt so also.
Das gemeinsame Management, ob das ein Traum ist, weiß ich nicht, aber.
Wir fangen zumindest mal damit an, dass man überhaupt bemisst, wie viel Platz braucht denn eine Mission eigentlich? Das kann man nämlich modellieren und das kann man auch mathematisch beschreiben und ähm da ähm sprechen wir uns international ab,
wie man sowas überhaupt bemessen kann.
Vielleicht so äh zum Ende hin nochmal ein Ausblick, was denn so für technologische Lösungen vielleicht noch gefunden werden können, weil jetzt haben wir schon festgestellt so, ah ja, total schwierig, die Dinger wieder einzufangen und äh,
ja gut das sind ja auch Sachen, wo man vorher drüber nachdenken könnte, ob man sowas nicht vielleicht bisschen einfacher macht, also ich meine so.
Wir haben ja nicht nur eine Müllabfuhr, sondern wir haben ja auch genormte Mülltonnen.
Ja?
Die passen dann halt an so ein Müllfahrzeug ran so ne oder früher waren die Mülltonnen ja noch,
Also noch nicht so reingehänkelt wurden, hatten sie zumindest diesen wunderbaren äh Knopf oben auf dem Deckel, dass man die und die waren rund und man konnte sie halt wunderbar so rollen und sowas, ne. Ähm.
Wenn man jetzt so überlegt, okay
Laufzeitverlängerung durch Nachtanken oder äh zumindest bessere Entsorgungssysteme, um einfach so ein Ding besser greifen zu können, so so einen Griff zum Wegwerfen sozusagen. Gibt's da auch schon Überlegungen in diese Richtung, da was äh anzustoßen?
Ja, du hast zehn, die die Antwort schon fast gegeben. Also das ist, das ist, das ist genau der Trend, also die die wir müssen die die Systeme natürlich auch vorbereiten für das Rückholen, also ähm wir müssen von vornherein standardisiert,
ich sag mal den Griff zum Wegschmeißen schon mit dran schrauben.
Ähm es ist aber nicht so profan wie das, also man könnte bei der Gelegenheit zum Beispiel auch Reflektoren an den Satelliten anbringen, der ihnen besser sichtbar macht, wo man vom Boden aus schon sehen kann,
wieder taumelt, dass man sich also aus schon mal auf die richtig das richtige Szenario einstellen kann vor dem Start und wenn es ans Wiederbetanken geht, dann muss man natürlich auch die entsprechende Schnittstelle haben, also quasi den Tank stutzen.
Der muss normiert sein und das stellt da stellt sich natürlich die Frage warum,
warum man baut man nicht gleich ähm die ganzen Satellitensysteme modular, so ein Baukasten, ja,
dieses dieses dieser dieser Würfel ist für für den für den Tank inklusive Stutzen. Ähm dieser ist für die Energieversorgung äh und und dann baut man den Satelliten im Prinzip,
ganz platt gesprochen, ne? Modular zusammen und dann könnte man dann auch im All äh sagen, okay, man kann eine Komponente ganz einfach austauschen, ne. Ein,
nicht mehr funktionsfähiges Energieversorgungssystem gegen anderes ersetzen.
Muss nicht gleich den ganzen Satelliten äh wegschmeißen. Wir nennen das ja äh in Orbit Recycling oder gewissermaßen Reparaturen durchführen.
Gewissermaßen ist dieses aktive Entfernen, was wir da zweitausendfünfundzwanzig erstmalig demonstrieren wollen, nur der erste Schritt, den.
Sich einem solchen Objekt anzunähern und das zu greifen ist Grundvoraussetzung
dass man das beherrscht, ähm, für alles weitere. Das Reparieren, das Wiederbetanken, das Recycling, das vielleicht sogar on Orbit Manufactoring, nennen wir das, also im Orbit sogar produzieren,
und dazu braucht man Standardisierung, wie du sagst, ähm Schnittstellen, Greifstellen.
Tanken zum Wiederbefüllen und so weiter. Das das ist in der Tat angedacht. Ein weiterer Trend.
Es geht übrigens auch bei der Bahn nicht sehr viel schneller. Also die Deutsche Bahn ist jetzt dabei, erst für die Güterzüge ein Kupplungssystem zu bauen, was automatisch ankoppeln kann, ja. Er hat auch Jahrzehnte gedauert.
Ja. Na ja, das ist halt die Freiheit, die man in der Raumfahrt hat, äh man sich sich irgendwas internationalen zu unterwerfen ist nicht gerade im Trend,
das mal sozusagen. Äh ja ich ich habe eben noch an an einem Trend gedacht, ähm einer Problematik, die jetzt noch so ein bisschen gefehlt hat, ist das Risiko am Boden.
Starten wir mehr, kommt auch mehr wieder runter.
Und auch in den letzten zehn Jahren ist zum Glück niemandem was passiert. Ist also keiner zu Schaden gekommen.
Dennoch muss man natürlich das sehr ernst nehmen, dass durch die Rom, wenn das jemand durch die Raumfahrt zu Schaden kommt, will man natürlich absolut nicht.
Aber wir fliegen nach wie vor, ähm kommen wir nicht drum rum, Tanks aus hitzefesten Material zu bauen, Titan, Edelstahl, Düsen und so weiter,
ebenfalls aus sitzfesten Material. Die werden den Wiedereintritt.
Durch die Atmosphäre überleben und dann auf dem Boden aufschlagen und das Problem haben wir auch in der Zukunft und dann vielleicht sogar vermehrt, weil noch viel mehr Raumfahrtsysteme unterwegs sind.
Da müssen wir nachdenken über ähm Design for dem. Also den Satelliten so auslegen, dass er verschwindet in der Atmosphäre,
und.
Oder landet.
Noch besser, noch besser landet. Ähm wahrscheinlich für große Satelliten kommt man nicht drum herum, die tatsächlich,
vielleicht kontrolliert zu entsorgen, also nicht irgendwo
über Land oder unkontrolliert ähm zum Absturz bringen, sondern gezielt über die Produzieren. Am liebsten natürlich auch wiederverwendbar.
Aber das werden wir, das, das, da sind wir noch weit von weg, aber es wäre schon mal, es wäre schon mal geholfen, wenn man's schafft, ähm den Satelliten so zu bauen, dass wenigstens der Großteil,
in der Etbad-Atmosphäre verglüht. Also Tanks aus Aluminium.
Ähm und ähm auch an andere kritische Komponenten, Optiken aus Material, was was besser aufschmilzt.
Basic so viel zurückholt, das dürft ihr euch freuen, oder?
Zurückholt.
Na ja, also das landet ja alles.
Ah, okay. Ja, du, du spielst an auf diese die Raketenstufe, die die wieder landet, aber die würde das ist die erste Stufe.
Die die würde die erreicht auch bei Wegwerfraketen nicht den Orbit, ne? Also das macht die Raumfahrt günstiger, was Basex da macht,
Aber das trägt jetzt nicht zum zum äh zum Vermindern des Problems im Allball, weil diese diese erste Stufe, die da wieder landet, die würde ohnehin nie den Orbit erreichen, auch nicht bei unseren Wegwerfsystemen, die wir, die wir haben.
Und die zweite Stufe.
Ja, wenn das einer schafft, eine eine wiederverwendbare zweite Stufe zu bauen, dann sind wir einen erheblichen Schritt weiter. Erheblichen Schritt weiter.
Aber die treten doch auch zumindest äh normalerweise wieder ein oder.
Ja, die treten wieder ein, aber die treten mit hobbytaler Geschwindigkeit wieder ein, das heißt die ähm treten mit ähm fünfundzwanzigtausend KMH ein.
Und das bewirkt, dass sie dermaßen starke Reibung mit der Atmosphäre haben beim Wiedereintritt,
Megawatt an Hitze frei werden, die das Objekt einfach aufschmelzen bis auf die Tanks. Und das ähm bei der ersten Stufe ist es so, die so langsam, wenn sie wieder runterkommt, dass die die Atmosphäre der, der nichts anhabt, ne,
Wenn man die zweite Stufe auch wieder verwenden will.
Dann muss man so viel Treibstoff mitnehmen, dass man die quasi vor dem Wiedereintritt komplett abbremst, ja? Dass sie wieder, dass sie wieder wieder einen Stein runterfällt, so wie die erste Stufe auch und dann kurz vorm vorm Aufriffen am Boden nochmal zünden, um sie
den Fall abzubremsen, aber das das ist dann schon
ganz schöner Eingriff in die in die Leistung der Rakete, wenn man da muss man ja quasi fast nochmal die gleiche Menge Treibstoff mitnehmen,
Nur für das, nur für das äh Abbremsen. Eigentlich sollte man das tun, ja.
Also ist die Frage, was billiger ist, ne? Also eine neue Rakete bauen oder äh mehr Treibstoff.
Ja, da das hat ähm in den Mast bestimmt durchgerechnet äh und jetzt ist dritte Neger gekommen, dass es sich das noch nicht lohnt, ne.
Ja heuer haben wir denn noch irgendeinen Aspekt vergessen? Meine Liste ist leer.
Ich glaube, dass wir alle wichtigen Themen angesprochen haben und äh sobald ich das gesagt habe, du ausgeschaltet hast, fehlt mir bestimmt eine Menge ein, aber dann ist es zu spät. Aber ich denke fürs erste äh ist es tatsächlich.
Du bist nicht du bist nicht frei von Hoffnung. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt viel über äh Probleme äh geredet und ähm manches hat sich halt auch nochmal verschärft, aber.
Das Problem wird ja dringend.
Auf eine gewisse Art und Weise, dass sie halt die ganze Industrie auch gefährdet. Das muss doch irgendwann mal so ein Tipping Point erreichen, wo dann auch äh gesagt wird, okay, jetzt müssen wir mal anders wirtschaften als bisher.
Wir haben wir haben ja immer gehofft, dass es so eine Art Rückwirkung gibt.
Des schlechten Verhaltens auf diejenigen, die die Raumfahrt betreiben, also dass sozusagen das Fehlverhalten direkt abgestraft wird, indem man zum Beispiel einen Satelliten verliert durch eine Kollision oder so, ja,
und jetzt merken wir mehr und das ist so rum, auch in den letzten zehn Jahren klar geworden, das ist so nicht. Ähm! Wir wir strafen,
durch unser Fehlverhalten heute nicht uns selber, sondern die zukünftigen Generationen ab. Und das ist immer problematisch. Wir kennen das ja auch vom Klima.
Ähm gibt es nicht nur direkte Rückwirkung des Fehlverhaltens ist so äh das menschliche Verhalten so, dass man sich noch ein bisschen Zeit lässt. Muss man vorsichtig zu sagen, ähm.
Und das ist schade, denn ähm der Betriebszyklus eines Satelliten über zehn Jahre,
oder die Lebensdauer einer Raumfahrtfirma über dreißig, vierzig Jahre ist nicht lang genug,
um diesen Zirkelschluss herzustellen. Wir reden über Konsequenzen, die in fünfzig bis hundert Jahren auftreten. Trotzdem aber heute behandelt werden müssen.
Ganz genau wie bei der CO zwei Problematik. Es ist viel günstiger heute zu handeln als in fünfzig Jahren, wenn man noch viel mehr Aufwand betreiben muss. Genauso ist die Problematik, die ja wegen der langzeitigen Wirkung aus Kollision und Kollision mit Fragmenten und der,
Kettenreaktionen, die dann sich langsam fortpflanzt, macht es Sinn, früh zu handeln, ist einfach billiger, aber wir handeln jetzt auf unsere Kosten,
um jemand anders in fünfzig Jahren, hundert Jahren das Leben leichter zu machen, das ist immer schwer zu verkaufen,
Das ist leider schwer zu verkaufen. Es wäre schöner, wenn es einen direkten Rückschluss gäbe, das dann würde es sofort jedem klar werden, aber,
Jedes Ereignis, was im Alt passiert, ähm leider,
was leider passiert, ähm jede Kollision, jeder Verlust eines Satelliten durch ähm Raumfahrtrückstände äh oder jede jeder nachgewiesene Einschlag bei hoch bei diesen hohen Geschwindigkeiten mit Schäden, die dabei entstehen.
Sind so ein Eyeopener, also die die Wecken rütteln die Leute wach, zumindest so für ein halbes Jahr, habe ich gemerkt, dass immer so der Horizont, wo das, wo das anhält und ähm dann die, die sagen wir mal so die der,
die Erkenntnis und der Wille, was zu tun war noch nie so stark, ähm wie heute. Das war vor zehn Jahren noch nicht so.
Raumklimawandel, ja? Vielleicht sollte man sozusagen den äh den Space-Lokdown äh ankündigen. Das könnten die Leute vielleicht auch verstehen, weil gerade bei der Virusbekämpfung haben wir ja auch so ähnliche Dynamiken. Das
dann immer auf den letzten Moment rausgeschoben wird und dann wird's eigentlich erst richtig teuer.
Wir wir bräuchten eine fünfhundertjährige Quarantäne.
Würde reichen, um die die Bahn bis achthundert Kilometer frei zu rollen.
Genau, gibt keine neuen Satelliten jetzt ist erstmal Schluss macht Pause.
Gut, hier soll jetzt auch erstmal Schluss. Äh ich mache natürlich keine Pause. Vielen Dank Holger, für die Ausführung zum Thema. Ja und äh vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Bald geht's wieder weiter. Bis dahin sag.